Now, we're gonna talk a little bit about what a consonant sound is.
A consonant sound is some kind of interruption in the vocal stream that creates a sound.
Sometimes it can be a very violent interruption like a /p/, /t/, /k/,...
...or a softer interruption like /l/ or /m/, or /ʒ/,...
In any case, some part of the articulators come together and create that interruption in the vocal stream.
Your consonants are either going to be voiced or voiceless.
In some cases, you'll have what we call consonant cognates or pairs.
These pairs of sounds are made in exactly the same place,...
...one is voiced and one is voiceless.
An example of that would be your "TH" sound /θ/, /ð/.
And there are many samples of that such as a /p/, /b/.
Okay, and some are just a simple interruption and there's no voiceless version like /m/,...
If there were a voiceless /m/, it would be like this...
...doesn't really make any sense, does it?
So, when you're working on your consonant sounds,...
...just notice them and work on them in your practice sessions.